we'll take five random topics then we'll
drop a beat and do a freestyle rap if
you are sat in this section here you
have suggestion number one what shall it
be
came the space time continuum thank you
so much it's really only the early show
that someone says that isn't it
three hours from now in here it's just
gonna be Jizzy dips Jizzy dicks Chris
in the fourth dimension what [__] that
guy's still here
um the space time continuum thank you I
didn't continue it might be one of my
favorite words I I any word that has
that like w
Ow like two that's quite cool isn't it
you um where else the Tulum that's the
place is that no it's not it's just one
one you okay anyway
um what are the words that have two U's
in them in a row vacuum well you you and
him should team up [__] get you
losers this is beautiful
but it's not pronounced like Continuum
is it you don't say vacuum
or maybe you do I don't know you
uh you spell color without a u right we
put one in anyway Linguistics funds face
time continuum
um front middle of the room and back
will come to you afterwards front middle
what would you like a rap about cars be
at a college bar Cosby at a college bar
I presume you you mean you say at yeah
yes that's what I said as well
um no no Bill Cosby right yeah cool is
there other others
are there other other college kit oh we
should not talk well we should let's
keep this that was a real we were on
each other's wavelengths weren't we this
man can't understand a word I say like
were there other Cosby's other college
kids yes at the bar
um
cool Cosby had a college bar because
he's he's out he's on the prowl isn't he
sorry he's
on the prowl on the loose
you can see him coming though it's a
very bright sweater so you you see him
he's not like me he's not just you know
rocking up like this maybe he is maybe
he's here
um
if Bill if you are do a set you're very
funny
um
you would watch him
um Cosby uh I just said Crosby I was
like no he just died right David
Crosby's not a college bar
um back of the room so far the
space-time Continuum pretty great Cosby
a college bar pretty bad back of the
room What's it gonna be okay there were
there were several uh there was some
Cheeky Monkey over here just going
colonization no
back of the room what do you want what
would you say
so you said what
kind of Lingus thank you and then there
was another one
David Attenborough taking a poo in
Trafalgar Square
[Laughter]
cunnilingus David Attenborough taking a
poo in Trafalgar Square space time
continuum Cosby a college bar final
suggestion Falls to this side of the
room what shall it be teeth great
why not why not just spin it just
straight into the point Chris this has
gone on too long
foreign
because we did the double vowel sound
right and she was like that's got one
teeth is great because because it's
singular form also has a double vowel
sound but with different letters right
let's um no other rapper will break down
their lexicon in this same way and uh
it's because it's not entertaining let's
make up a wrap
um delightful band I would love you to
construct a beat right now in front of
their very ears and I will follow with a
rap about all that [__] you said if you
don't like the rap it's your fault you
were the ones that kicked the things so
let's do this I know the frustration of
the guy colonization shout it out I'm
like now in the situation I wanna pick
something else maybe bring this let me
go down rap about the cunnilingus I'll
be focusing on this when I'm younger not
older I was not caring about the fault
of the vulver but now I've got the
experience to know the knowledge I'm
taking out the vulva you know I
acknowledge there's a labian minora
Majora two so many sizes like animal was
in that Zoo David Attenborough he's
hanging out there and he quits to zoom
move into Trafalgar Square he says this
is lovely I should report on animals but
now I've been caught short usually that
means you need to go number two he sees
the fountain what does he do he says
well of course I should be trying I go
there on Nelson's column with the four
Lions I sit down I know it's really
quite wrong it's made out of concrete
not Bronze in the pond he starts curling
out a big brown turd people say wow
David's observed to you like 92 or 93
sat there in your Safari finary and he
narrates while he shits just a little
bit he goes oh no I've got the squids
that's diarrhea and make it kind of
clear but back to cunnilingus like
elephant ears that's my favorite size
they're at the side all flush with blood
the clitoris can hide inside actually
it's a very large organ but if you go
inside it's very rewarding there's the
G-Spot I'm coming on strong I start
curling up a prehensile tongue getting
all the places that the fingers can't
reach getting inside sucking blood like
a leech apologies for that image we
raped and we pillaged we came overseas
any Indian village we said we plant a
flag and now we're back there I still
did the colonizing but my friend doesn't
care and that's fine yes deep beneath
the gums if you're a baby you've got
some teeth then they come start going up
they start to part the bit of Flesh if
you are a shark then hark there's so
many rows more than you know they come
out and then they protrude and then
close teeth made out of calcium and some
other stuff dentine you can see them in
the skulls of dinosaurs but they're just
fossils over here in the time machine
Full Throttle I turn it up everybody
stands to attention call me Doctor Who I
Traverse the dimension between space
10 times yeah the Tardis the core box
that's mine you can find me I travel I
have a blast I use the space-time
Continuum and move to the past I walk
into a bar and then I acknowledge I'm
like 33 it's kind of weird this is just
a college establishment everybody's in
their 20s early side how many ladies
plenty I look around I'm kind of kind of
groovy they're dancing I see a sweater
looking like a coogee I say oh [__] I'll
do it properly we're back in time
remember I'm here to stop Cosby people
should say you should kill Baby Hitler
but no I'm like this is the guy that I
picked her I said look to Bill and say
what do you think a catch him in the air
to dropping pills in a drink I say stop
take your hand away no sir Bill Cosby
not today he says okay and walks out the
door and who's coming in I'm enthralled
as [__] David he stands there in the
frame says hello yes I've got great aim
and a good name he punches Cosby in the
face and then he poo yeah just all over
the place
[Applause]